en el vídeo anterior reescribir la
ecuación del resorte sustituyendo la
fuerza por la masa por aceleración y
estaba en el proceso de decir si x está
en función al tiempo cuál va a ser la
aceleración vimos que la velocidad es la
derivada de x con respecto al tiempo o
el cambio de posición entre el cambio
del tiempo y la aceleración es el cambio
de la velocidad o la derivada de la
velocidad o la segunda derivada de la
posición ahora vamos a reescribir esta
ecuación de masa por aceleración igual a
menos la constante del resorte por
la distancia
como una ecuación diferencial en estos
términos aquí queda entonces voy a
escribir en blanco
queda
massa
por la aceleración que la aceleración es
la segunda derivada de x o del
desplazamiento con respecto al tiempo
que es igual a menos la constante del
resorte por la distancia como función
del tiempo
esto que acabo de escribir es una
ecuación diferencial y que es una
ecuación diferencial es aquella en la
que no sólo se tienen funciones sino
también derivadas de dicha función y la
solución a una ecuación diferencial no
es solamente un número o un conjunto de
números la solución de una ecuación
diferencial será una función o una clase
de funciones o algún conjunto de
funciones en este ejemplo no vamos a
resolver esta ecuación de manera
analítica sino que usaremos nuestra
intuición de lo que hicimos
anteriormente para encontrar la solución
a esta ecuación diferencial de manera
que si funciona podremos saber la
posición de la masa en cualquier
instante del tiempo
esta es una ecuación diferencial cuando
dibujamos esta función que nuestra
intuición nos indica que es una función
coseno con amplitud
es esta función wv va a ser nuestra
velocidad angular ahora lo que hacemos
es probar esta función para ver si
satisface esta ecuación diferencial si
dijéramos que x de t
es igual a jose no de
primera derivada de x con respecto a t
va a ser igual a es una constante esa se
mantiene la derivada de la función
coseno con respecto al tiempo si hay
alguna constante que está multiplicando
a nuestra variable de interés va a salir
entonces va a ser x w y la derivada del
coche no es menos
seno de lo que tiene entre paréntesis
que viene siendo w
que lo podemos reescribir menos a w
seno de w y esta es la primera derivada
si queremos saber la segunda derivada
que la voy a escribir en otro color
la segunda derivada
de x con respecto al tiempo pues va a
ser la derivada de esto la derivada de
un seno de lo que tiene adentro con
respecto al tiempo va a hacer
esta constante que está multiplicando a
mi variable va a salir también iba a ser
coseno de lo que tiene aquí adentro
entonces estos son constantes
voy a ser igual a menos a ahora en lugar
de ser w solita es doblegó al cuadrado
por el coste no de
ahora vamos a ver si esto es correcto
voy a hacer un poco más de espacio aquí
y voy a mover esto
de manera que ahora si esto fuera cierto
yo podría decir que
la masa
sustituyó esto por este desarrollo por
menos
w al cuadrado coseno de w
es igual a menos
lo que está en esta ocasión menos
can
por xd xd quedamos que es esto menoscaba
por a kossen o de w
aquí como ven sustituir
esta segunda derivada en esta parte y
aquí sustituye xp por coseno de w
veamos si podemos simplificar esto voy a
ponerlo con otro color
esta parte lo puedo poner como menos m
por a w al cuadrado kosen o de w
y bueno esto es igual a menos que a
coseno de w
podemos quitar estos signos de menos y
dividir a ambos lados de la ecuación
entre a por lo que podría reescribir
esta ecuación como m
post
wv al cuadrado coseno de w y esto es
igual a k por coseno de w
hasta este momento luce bastante bien
esta ecuación solo va a ser verdadera si
se cumple que esta parte es igual a esta
es decir que sí
m
qué es la masa por doble o al cuadrado
es igual a la constante del resorte
que también puedo expresarlo como w al
cuadrado es igual a k / m
o también puedo decir que w 1 es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de k / m
y con esto pues ya encontré la ecuación
diferencial que es verdadera y que
describe la función de x con respecto al
tiempo siempre y cuando esto se cumpla
vuelva a ser un poquito más despacio
aquí abajo por lo que podemos decir
que la función que hemos encontrado la
función x de t
y que esta función x dt es igual a a
jose no
encontramos el valor de w wv es raíz de
k
/ m
por el tiempo y con esto podemos saber
exactamente cuál va a ser la posición de
la masa en cualquier instante en el
tiempo y esto para mí es sorprendente
pues usamos algo de cálculo sencillo
resolvimos una ecuación diferencial y
ahora podemos saber con exactitud la
posición de resorte en cualquier
instante del tiempo